hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that uh pretty much just
finished from the super bet chess
classic it's a round three levona ronan
versus celeressa first and this is one
game that um uh when you when you
see the moves you will not believe how
the game actually ended uh but that's
one of the cool things about chess you
never know until the game is finished so
let's dive straight into it there is a
quite a lot to enjoy if you're wondering
why i'm wearing a suit i am attending a
wedding after after this video so that
is the reason uh now getting back to the
game uh levon has the white pieces and
he opens with c4 uh we have c6 violet
going for this um sort of a car contact
structure against the english opening
knight to f3 we have d5 and d4 now uh
transposing into the slop defense knight
to f6 knight to c3 and d captures on c4
we have a for now now stopping b5 and
the bishop there five by alireza uh
knights the e5 and knight b to d7 so
this has all been played before nothing
out of the ordinary here knight captures
on c4 grabbing back the pawn queen to c7
and g3 now preparing to think finger to
the light square bishop with e5 now
striking in the center d captures knight
captures and now bishop to f4 attacking
the knight here the knight of course
cannot move the queen is on c7 so knight
after d7 adding a defender here also uh
you will be able to add more uh uh
support here for the knight with a move
like f6 bishop to g2 and now uh pawn to
g5 trying to get the bishop uh away from
the the square if you of course if you
capture on g5
uh then we're just going to capture the
three knight on c4 that's not an option
so knight to e3 going after the uh the
bishop on f5 and then now g captures on
it for knight captures on f5 and queen
side castles by alireza so you can see
that alireza has a very
nice setup here and attacking formation
and uh
levon still has to figure out what to do
with the king of course you do not want
your queen on d1 so queen to c2 first
and a nice prophylactic king to b8 we
have g captures on f4 now grabbing this
pawn attacking the knight knight to c4
and now pawn to e3 uh so what can you do
here you are up a pawn but your king is
on e1 and where are you gonna hide the
king uh knight to c five valeresa now
rook to d1 offering a rook trade which
uh alireza goes for we have captures
knight captures uh sorry not queen
captures knight captures and now comes a
queen to a5 with check and the position
has been reached before uh and uh well
just like the c3 pretty much stops
everything but already played pretty
much everything up until this point
instantly and levon had to burn a lot of
time he wasn't um
uh acquainted with the intricacies of
the position as much as alireza so he
decided after some uh
well uh not not an incredibly long thing
an incredibly long thing actually
happened after this move but he played
king to e2 and it is now only as of move
19 that we have a completely new game
but it's also a move that allows alireza
to completely take over the game grab
initiative and push for an absolute win
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out what levon missed with
this king the e2 idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
can actually win a pawn here and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is queen to a6 now luckily queen
to a6 is the move you play even if you
don't see why it's good because it just
looks so aesthetically pleasing and now
you are threatening some very nasty
discoveries here for example knight a3
check will just pick up the queen so
white has to be very careful and if you
play something like king the e1 then we
just capture on a4 and that's it now we
have a winning game because of b3 then
bishop will be for check and you don't
have a good square for the king king f1
knight captures on e3 now gonna
grab the queen next and that's it so
instead after queen to a6 king the f3
this is what levon had planned uh queen
captures on a4 that's the move that uh
levon missed and the one that alvareza
had in mind now the problem is uh how do
you continue here do you capture the
queen or do you play something else well
it's only moved 20 and levon spent over
an hour here it's uh i believe some one
hour and five minutes for this move uh
which is incredible as that's uh that's
a lot of time to burn uh it's uh i i
always like to mention how uh braunstein
spent uh
like 15 minutes for uh for playing the
first move in that famous game against
snyder but here uh it's just um
well
there's not all that uh much uh to
consider uh other than capturing the
queen because if you play something like
knight to d4 okay you can defend your
queen uh we're gonna capture and after
knight captures just knight to b3 and
the the two knights here are just
monsters next you're gonna start pushing
these pawns and okay not that arrow
but it's going to be very stop hard to
stop
all of these pawns so that's one way to
do it
the other one is queen captures an a4
but now after knight captures uh what
alireza found when he played queen to a6
is that you can play b3 here and that's
probably what all of you found when you
decided that queen to a6 was the best
idea so congratulations on that uh the
problem is if you play b3 here then just
knight to d2 with check we checked the
king king e2 and now knight capture
spawn now we have three connected past
pawns here of course this is completely
winning for black so levon tried king to
e2 and now we have knight captures on b2
uh knight captures on b2 and the knight
capture so rook to b1 uh levon brings
the rook into the game knight to a4 so
it's still uh uh black is up only one
pawn but three connected pass pawns on
the queen side will be very very hard to
to deal with so here we have king to d2
knight to b6 and bishop to f3 now
uh and now comes bishop to c5
uh developing the bishop preparing to
bring the rook into the game knight h6
going after the f7 pawn now comes f6 we
have rook back to g1 now going for that
uh g7 square and a5 already starts
pushing the the past pawns we have
rooked the g8 now
forcing a rook trade rook captures
knight captures and uh here we have pawn
to f5 not allowing e4 and also
just uh controlling these three pawns
basically with with one f pawn so here
king to c2 now the king will have to uh
work very hard to stop those those pawns
uh a4 all it is that continues pushing
knight to h6 going after the f5 pawn and
now knight to c4
so what can you play here well now you
could grab the pawn on f5 the problem is
after a3 it's going to be very very hard
to
to stop those pawns so here we have
bishop to e2 instead uh challenging the
knight for uh for from such an active
square knight to d6 and now bishop to d3
we have knight to e4 as now the the f5
pawn is attacked twice you could play
king to c7 as an active king here is
definitely worth a pawn but
there's no point in giving it away so 94
we have bishop captures f captures and
now knight the g8 here we have b5 now
the pawns are pretty much unstoppable uh
it it's uh
like i said you will be watching this
game but you will not be able to figure
out how it ends uh knight to f6 uh we
have king to c7 finally uh bringing the
king into the game knight captures on h7
now uh levon also with uh two pass pawns
uh b4 and now knight to g5 and it's
moved 39 so two more moves are needed
for time control to be reached uh levon
has some five minutes on the clock
alireza has 15 minutes on the clock
uh and here he plays pawn to b3 with
check
much stronger here uh is um uh advancing
the king because as you'll see this will
be crucial in winning this game the king
has to come to c4 so b3 can be played b3
is a light square we have a dark square
bishop so we need a way to push b3
however in the game b3 check was played
right away and now after king to b2 uh
you will have a hard time playing a3 as
the b3 pawn is now undefended so we
still need our king and c4 so bishop to
be for first uh probably to avoid knight
to d6 check and enforcing a trade here
then the white pawns are also very very
fast uh this way the dark square bishop
really keeps an eye on those past pawns
so bishop to b4 and now knight captures
on e4 and here we have c5 and c5
is the moment where alireza ruins the
game basically and this is move 41 so
time control has been reached uh but
it's not uncommon after
reaching time control that you still
just you know play a move that you were
considering during your calculations
when you were in time trouble and now
when you have additional time uh you
still play the the move that
does not win the game for you here again
king b6 we have to not that obviously
but we have to bring the king to c4 we
have to guard the b3 pawn and then push
a3 and that's pretty much it h4 king b5
and after let's say h5 king c4 that's uh
that's all there is
uh you you can't deliver a check here or
here as the bishop covers both of these
squares so that's uh well just works in
our favor and after h6 a3 check that's
it whatever black plays we're just gonna
push bishop c3 and now of course the
pawns are completely winning a2 a1 is
the game over uh so and of course if h7
the bishop also nicely controls that if
you if you capture uh for example uh
after after this h7 pawn uh we're just
gonna play a2 and if you capture on c3
of course a1 check is much much faster
after the king after the king moves
we're just going to capture here we
guard the queening square we're going to
deliver a checkmate very soon so after
knight captures on e4 alright played c5
and this allows lavon this brilliant
brilliant knight to c3 and this is a
spectacular knight the c3 is the only
move that saves the game for lebron and
now you see the problem you can't push
this because you lose the b3 pawn you
can't push the c pawn because knight d5
trick picks up the bishop on b4 so by
going for this setup of pushing this
pawn that um
you simply didn't have to push it you
could have just brought the king to c4
uh that now you don't have a move so
bishop captures and c3 was played by
elereza king captures now c4 trying to
give up this pawn to try and advance
this pawn but not just king b2 and now
the keep kings uh that keeps the
pawns at bay here king d6 finally the
king starts marching forward f5 we have
king e5 now comes f3 king captures on f5
now pawn to h4 we have king to e5 now h5
king to f5 and pawn to f4 uh looks uh
like uh there might be something here
but there is not king to e4 we have h6
king to d3 now now okay you have a pass
pawn but here comes c3 with check king
to a3 now comes c2 uh h8 with queen and
now c1 with queen so both players now
get a second queen in the game king
captures on a4 and now pawn to b2 and it
seems like um alireza will bring another
queen into the game however first he has
to uh get out of all the checks so queen
h7 check king captures on e3 queen h3
cha king captures on
an f4 and now queen the h for with check
and now uh how can uh how can levon uh
get out of this uh can uh can alireza
hide the king somehow to
advance this pawn to a second queen or
will levon be able to figure something
out the king the f5 queen h3 check king
e5 uh we have queen the h5 with check
king to d6 now comes queen g6 check king
to c7 and now the beautiful queen g7
check and that's all there is you either
come forward and then we repeat the
process or you play king to b6 and here
uh levone just played queen captures on
b2 and now of course there is nothing to
be done as the king is in check the
queen is also attacked the queen has to
be captured and he was in this position
on move 62 that we have a draw by
stalemate
so really really incredible stuff uh
alireza uh got a winning position he
found that a beautiful beautiful uh
winning idea very very early on in the
game as of move uh 19 basically the
first move that lavone made a mistake
alireza punished it with queen to a6 he
won the pawn and he had everything
needed to actually win uh but uh when it
uh was most important uh and uh well
when you had to march your king over to
guard the b3 pawn to execute a3 uh he
pushed the c5 pawn and that was enough
for lavon to find the brilliant knight
to c3 save and that's basically the
story of this game so incredibly
incredible stuff i thought really
alireza would would take this one uh but
the other one uh just kept fighting
until the very end and for some reason
even though time control has been
reached uh after this um king to b2 by
lavon uh and the bishop to b4 knight
captures an e4 alireza still played this
on move 41. maybe he thought it was move
40 maybe he thought he was uh
he had to reach time control or maybe he
just thought that all of it was winning
knight to c3 is a easy move to miss but
not in a classical game where you have
all this time in the world
uh so yeah top break for alireza after a
lost uh to nipple getting a draw out of
a completely winning game against levon
but excellent excellent uh maneuvering
by lavone uh for for surviving this uh
onslaught of young alireza
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really really wonderful stuff
uh i would like to thank mihail calbera
asher fine joshua hadley queen c and
bonfire berto for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing to
cover this wonderful event until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend